[Musique]
nos portables sont devenus
indispensables
nous appelons gère nous rendez vous
notre santé notre vie sentimentale
mais si une appli pouvez vous dire
combien de temps il me reste 63 ans 57
ans il vous reste à vivre
voudriez vous savoir toujours cette api
elle est bidon c'est évident ma copine
disait pareil ça prébois tour
cette appli savait qu'elle allait mourir
[Applaudissements]
ce qui nous arrive
je crois que c'est à cause de cette
appli je veux tout changer changer de
portable de numéro et d'opérateurs vous
avez besoin d'autre chose non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'appli candidat c'est l'affichage
aléatoire d'un nombre une horloge faut
pas flipper pour ça j'ai comme
l'impression vous vous êtes fait avoir
c'est la liste de tous ceux qui ont
téléchargé l'appli elle n'a téléchargé
tout ce qu'on a à faire c'est de
devancer l'horloge d'une seconde
est ce que tu as déjà réussi à faire ce
genre de choses non mais j'ai beaucoup
lu à ce sujet si ça marche pas une
malédiction bien pire que la mort vous
poursuivre à six mois elle vous
accablera
il finira par vous détruire
qu'est-ce qu'il ya tu m'a appelé
[Musique]